[Music]
Bayesian - Oh our pure natural
refreshing mineral water comes from the
ancient river stats best of all a bottle
of Bayesian 200 has 200 milligrams of
Bayesian mineral that four to five
doctors believe reduces the risk of
addition Alice Jimmy goes to the grocery
store Bayes Mart to buy some water he
wonders what the company means when they
say a bottle of Bayesian 200 has 200
milligrams of Bayesian it's that on
average could it vary a lot by bottle
and how many doctors were surveyed and
how can they distinguish correlation
from causation hmm
sources faysville continued operas and
or discrete town are there major
differences between these sources three
segments of the stats River are used as
sources for Bayesian 201 in Bayes ville
one in continue Appa less and one in
discrete town
the average Bayesian level is different
for these three sources on average a
bottle source from Bayes Ville has 250
milligrams of Bayesian bottle from
continued Oppel us has a hundred and
ninety milligrams and a bottle from
discrete town has 160 milligrams even
within each of these sources there is
variation for a random bottle how much
Bayesian do you expect it to contain is
it the simple average 200 milligrams a
it is the simple average B it's more
than the simple average C it's less than
the simple average or D it depends as in
so many other situations the answer is
that it depends
the average Bayesian level is a weighted
average of the separate average Bayesian
levels for the three cities where the
weights depend on what proportion of
water is sourced from each of the cities
the simple average makes sense if
one-third of the water comes from each
of the cities
but if for example 2/3 of the water
comes from discrete town and only
one-sixth comes from Bay's ville and 1/6
from continue Appa less then the overall
average is 180 milligrams in general let
Y be the Bayesian content of a random
water bottle and B C and D be the events
that the water in the bottle comes from
Bay's ville continuous and discrete town
respectively then the overall average is
a weighted average of the separate
averages the expected value of y is e of
Y given B P of B plus e of y given C P
of C plus e of Y given D P of D let X be
a random variable that indicates which
city the water comes from say with x
equals 1 meaning Bayes Ville X equals 2
meaning continued appleís and x equals 3
meaning discrete town the above identity
can be expressed even more compactly as
a of y equals e of a of Y given X this
identity is known as iterated
expectation or Adams law
Jimmy is also concerned about how much
the Bayesian content varies by bottle
not just the average amount in a bottle
suppose that a bottle is equally likely
to be sourced from each of the three
cities for each source water bottles
have a standard deviation of 10
milligrams in their Bayesian content
what is the overall standard deviation
of Bayesian content in a random water
bottle a 10 milligrams be more than 10
milligrams C less than 10 milligrams or
D it depends is the overall variance the
weighted average of the three separate
variances
we can answer Jimmy's question visually
if the answer is yes then moving a
cities pile will not change the overall
standard deviation but in general the
overall standard deviation does change
when we move a pile even though we are
not changing the separate standard
deviations the key is that there are two
types of variation the Bayesian content
varies within each city and it also
varies between cities remarkably we can
get the overall variance simply by
adding these two contributions the
variance of y is e of the variance of Y
given X plus the variance of e of Y
given X the first term is the average of
the separate variances for each city the
second term is the variance between the
separate averages for each city this
identity is known as eaves law in this
example the variance of Y given X is 100
since within each city the variance is
100 and a of Y given X is 250 if x
equals 1 190 if x equals 2 and 160 if x
equals 3 which gives that the variance
of e of Y given X is 1400 by eaves law
the variance of Y is 100 plus 1400 which
is 1500 the standard deviation is the
square root of this variance which is
about 40 milligrams this is much higher
than 10 milligrams just using the
average of the three separate variances
ignores the second term in eves law
Jimny is right to be skeptical and to
seek more refined data with multiple
sources of water there are multiple
sources of variation
[Music]
you